joining me now is Missouri Senator Eric
Schmidt and former senior adviser to
president Trump Steven Miller Senator uh
the American people have been clued in
on what's really happening here they
have had the bulk of this bill the key
Provisions they've had this stuff
finalized for weeks and weeks and weeks
but now they're going to release it on
Sunday it looks like and Rush the vote
on Wednesday
really oh it's a total joke and uh if
you think about this Chuck Schumer has
announced we're going to be voting on
this next week for a bill that no one's
seen that's been negotiated with a
president who could close the border
right now but chooses not to and a and a
Secretary of Homeland Security that's
about to be impeached okay so what are
they really hiding it kind of reminds me
of that line in the first vacation uh
where Eugene Le is the used car sales
when he's talking to to Chevy Chase and
he he pulls up the family truckster and
says you think you hate it now way do
you drive it so I can only imagine but
what we do know is very concerning Joe
Biden has all the tools in need right
now but think about that but this is
emblematic of Chuck Schumer the way he
does it to cram this thing last moment
moment to sort of come down from you
know uh like Moses with the Ten
Commandments nobody can amend it nobody
has time to review it it's certainly not
going to a committee we should spend
weeks talking about this amending of it
it's not going to happen it's not going
to happen it's ridiculous this this
affects the entire future the culture
the economy of the United States of
America but we have um congressman like
Republican Dan krenshaw slamming
Republicans for not just jumping on
board with the Border Bill watch this
the height of stupidity is having a
strong opinion on something you know
nothing about I'm I'm extremely
disappointed in the very strange
maneuvering by many on the right to to
to
torpedo uh a potential border Reform
Bill if we have a bill that on net
significantly decreases illegal
immigration and we sabotage that that is
that is inconsistent with what we told
our Vo we would do people will make up
whatever reasons they they want to
there's a number of them I'm sure but it
would be a pretty unacceptable
dereliction of of your
duty Steph Miller tough words from khaw
a
dereliction of Duty very indignant he is
what does he get wrong
here the dereliction of Duty is not
going to Chuck Schumer Mitch McConnell
Joe Biden and by the way all the
Democrats up for re-election this year
like John tester and shered brown and
saying here is our offer zero illegal
immigrants why don't you stand up before
the American people and say why the
number should be 2 million or 3 million
or whatever is authorized in this bill
have a national debate about the number
Z
0.0 that's the correct number of illegal
immigrants we're talking about an
Administration that right now allowed
illegal aliens to beat cops and go free
they could have sent with one phone call
ICE officers to that Courthouse arrested
those illegals and shipped them back
home we were talking about a Democrat
Party that just in the last 48 hours
voted against Republican bills in the
house to deport illegal immigrants with
DUI convictions and who have committed
Social Security fraud and identity theft
the Democratic party is committed to
open borders and it's time for
Republicans to stop being afraid stop
hiding stop cowering and to demand a
great national public referendum on
whether or not Joe Biden should be
allowed to release any deportable alien
into this country at all and I dare John
tester to explain to his voters why he
thinks we should have 2 million 3
million 5 million 10 million illegal
aliens added to this country by Joe
Biden or anyone else for that matter
Laura Senator what's ultimately going to
happen here with
this Well here here's what can happen
next week when Chuck Schumer tries to
Ram this down everybody's throat it it
takes 41 Republicans in the Senate to
stand up and say we're not going to do
this we're not going to go along with
this we're not going to allow you to do
this this is the stuff that people hate
about Washington we're going to side
with the American people we're going to
side with the Republican house we're not
going to side with Chuck Schumer we're
not going to side with Joe Biden we're
actually going to stand up for the
American people we're going to stand up
for the sovereignty of our own borders
and that's what we need to do next
week 41 will we have those numbers we
should um but it's going to be tough
given that leadership Senator Stephen
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else